allez-y
elles sont 450 barreau 2 à se donner
rendez vous au sri-lanka répartis en
équipes de deux ou de trois les amazones
se défieront pendant six jours vtt canoë
trail tir à l'arc 2 yvelinoise ont
décidé de se lancer dans cette aventure
là le raid amazones au sri lanka c'est
ça va être absolument génial de pouvoir
aller à la rencontre des gens de visiter
un pays de s'intégrer dans la culture
dominique elle participe avec ses deux
filles virginie 44 ans et aurélie 40 ans
elle représente l'équipe des wonder
serait elle-même la de reprendre leurs
compétitions toutes les trois c'est un
vrai plaisir même si je sais que ça va
être du révérend des hauts et des bas ça
va être très dur mais bon voilà on verra
la découverte le raid amazones c'est
aussi l'occasion de se dépasser
physiquement pour une cause
c'est l'occasion d'en parler à travers
nos réseaux sociaux et puis d'essayer dé
soutenir un peu plus que d'habitude
financièrement justement avec aussi ce
qu'on pourra avoir de nos partenaires
mon petit fils est atteint d'un syndrome
un syndrome épileptique syndrome de drap
s il mal à dire à 350 cas en france donc
ça entraîne des des retards
psychomoteurs
une mort subite
voilà tahoua 14 ans et donc on
représente l'association de tao et c'est
notre comment je vais dire notre point
d'ancrage setao voilà dès qu'il ya un
petit problème tao voilà notre
entraînement tout ça c'est alors une
aventure sportive solidaire et humaine
il ya aussi des amitiés thinès et à
travers ses amitiés on apprend tout à se
connaître et pendant les épreuves c'est
super quel que soit le niveau on
s'encourage tout même la dernière où
l'attend on lui fait la ola et surtout
on est impressionné par les dernières
même des fois parce que elles ont moins
de temps de repos entre deux épreuves
que nous forcément et il ya aussi des
raids ou les femmes viennent pour se
dépasser même si elles sont malades même
si elle suit des traitements et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on qu'on partage
énormément pour célébrer les 20 ans du
raid amazones deux courses ont été
organisées dominique est déjà revenu
avec ses deux filles elles ont terminé
18e sur 28 de son côté marie sera dans
l'avion pour le sri lanka dimanche 27
mars